hi I'm Talulah Riley and I'm really
excited to be releasing my debut novel
act of love acts of love is a modern-day
love story it's about a woman called
Bernadette who is a journalist and has
made her career out of profiling
successful men and then divulging their
secrets and she lures them into a false
sense of security and then it's quite
mean about them but at some point she
meets Bradley Blake who she is sent to
interview and he challenges all of the
assumptions that she's had about the
male gender the inspiration for writing
the book was because I started thinking
about male romantic characters in
literature you know from mr. Rochester
to Christian Grey and how a lot of those
characters tended to have quite
misogynistic tendencies and I wondered
if he could have a female protagonist
who was equally as bad in ways usually
leveled at women so sexually
manipulative conniving you know just out
out Fernand and I wondered whether that
would still be considered an attractive
character by people my biggest literary
inspiration for acts of love was gone
with the wind because of the character
of Scarlett O'Hara who was the original
female badass so I wanted to write a
modern-day Scarlett I have always wanted
to be a writer I've written my whole
life journaling poetry prose screenplays
and it's really exciting to be having a
published novel because it's a child
country
you